Kev Durant was asked how he feels about
being Victor W Bama's favorite
basketball player and here is what he
had to say I'm old of course old and
basketball terms is not old in real life
but if we are talking in a basketball
sense Katie is Right some of our
favorite players are way older than we
want to admit everyone knows Braun is
about to turn 39 CP3 is also 38 Stephen
KD are 35 James Harden Russell Westbrook
and Jimmy Butler are 34 so put that all
in perspective while some play past 40
most NBA players retire in their mid to
late 30s guys like Kobe and Carmelo
retired at age 38 Alan Iverson retired
at 36 Tracy McGrady retired when he was
34 sometimes it's easy to forget due to
the fact that several of these dudes are
still somehow playing Prime basketball
but as Katie said in NBA terms he is old
it's pretty surreal to think that we are
watching an incredible era of basketball
enter its final years and that's why we
cannot take watching these guys for
granted